[Musique]
les gens qui sont enthousiastes qui
m'encourage qui qui m'envoient des
messages très positif il ya d'autres qui
sont en train de se moquer de mazout et
de menaces et je reçus mêle des menaces
de mort pour eux candidat gay n'est pas
sérieux c'est pas sérieux d'annoncés sur
l'homosexualité dans le cadre d'une
offre de cure à la présidentielle mais
moi c'est les médias qui parlent de ça
moi j'ai jamais mis en avant mon
orientation sexuelle
en plus pourquoi on pose pas la question
aux autres candidats sur l'orientation
sexuelle
[Musique]
rien n'est dit des choses c'est ne pas
trois ans seulement parce que moi en
tant que militant pour la cause a répété
je connais plusieurs personnes et ont
été pendant les trois ou quatre fois à
des peines lourdes homosexualité c'est à
dire le mot sexuels quand ils sont de
prison il va pas changer d'orientation
sexuelle
on sait très bien que la prison ne
changent pas leur orientation sexuelle
et quand il va sortir de prison il va
rester homosexuels il va revenir en
prison
et ça toute sa vie ça veut dire si une
condamnation à perpétuité pas à trois
ans seulement
[Musique]
il faut un débat sur la cause lgbt en
tunisie sur les exactions sont en train
d'être commise barral gouvernement
contre les homosexuels sur la torture de
la police pratiqué contre les
homosexuels sur le test annales qui
utilisait comme preuves et qui est une
ordure horrible pratiqués sur les
homosexuels sur l'utilisation des
données personnelles des personnes
homosexuelles pour prouver leur
homosexualité en utilisant leurs photos
leurs conversations sur les réseaux
sociaux leur vidyo tout ça et c'est une
atteinte à la vie privée est atteinte
aux données personnelles sur le fait qu'
il ya beaucoup de d'agression sexuelle
dans les prisons contre les homosexuels
[Musique]